and this is we were coming up I think
it's what the seventh or eighth real
person
you've played if if the people are still
alive do you do you like to meet them do
you seek them out yes and in fact I say
to them I've said this to Richard
Phillips and I said it to Charlie Wilson
Jim Lovell I said now look I'm playing
you so for good or for bad I'm you
mm-hmm and you're gonna get that for a
long time I'm you deal with it now as
you I'm going to say things you never
said go places you never work I'm gonna
do things you never did that be the case
I'd like to be as authentic as possible
are you just looking for their blessing
or do you could have absorbed something
do you get something out I do want to
know what they had to say about it cuz
they've always read this replay and I
want to say if you think anything is
absolute horse [ __ ] in this let me know
because did what did I just
[Laughter]
once again we've got he delivered right
here
your top-notch show you want to know
what they have any problems because
there's things that just would never
happen you wonder if you want to be
right inauthentic but really what I'm
looking for is a tick a gesture a
posture way to stand a turn of phrase
that I could that I can turn into my own
and reflect them somehow because it's
inevitable that we will be queuing up
see the Anthony Joshua story so when the
biopic is made who would you like to
play you
[Applause]
[Music]
I will take things you never said you
are good
[Music]
you